[Applaus]
morgens auf hof booten land
[Musik]
karin möglichst keine bäuerin sie pflegt
tiere
schwein friederich ist von einem
tiertransporter in die freiheit
gesprungen rosa stammt aus einer
mastanlage dort vegetierte sie schwer
krank vor sich hin
zusammen mit ihrem lebenspartner jan
gerdes kümmert sie sich in erster linie
um kühe die nach vielen jahren in der
landwirtschaft eigentlich beim
schlachter gelandet wären
aufruf booten land können die tiere ihre
letzten jahre in ruhe verbringen
wir haben hier das essen vorbereitet für
die alten damen und herren aus der
pflegeabteilung kann man sagen die
leiden alle unter arthrose und schaffen
es nicht mehr mit der großen herde
mitzulaufen
als spinner werden sie von manch einem
landwirt in der gegend abgetan
doch ihr projekt hat inzwischen so viele
unterstützer dass sie mit den spenden
gut für ihre 38 kinder sorgen können
marieke ist ein pflegefall
sie hat zwölf jahre lang im stall
gestanden
anbindehaltung heißt das im fachjargon
mehr als 100.000 liter milch hat sie in
dieser zeit gegeben
die pflegerin mit findet es grausam dass
in der milchwirtschaft die tiere oft wie
maschinen behandelt werden die
verbraucher wissen einfach zu wenig
meint sie es gibt ebenso viele märchen
beispielsweise eine kuh gibt eben immer
milch dass die dafür erst mal ein kalb
bekommen muss und in der heutigen
industrie haltung ist es ja so sie wird
auch noch zwangs besamt sie kriegt das
ja nicht freiwillig dann wird ihr das
kalb weggenommen damit wir milch trinken
können
ihr partner jan gerdes hatte den
elterlichen hof zunächst als biobauer
weitergeführt bis er ganz aus der
landwirtschaft ausgestiegen ist
andere landwirte kritisieren ihn dafür
sie müssten hart arbeiten während er
doch nur spenden einsammeln würde doch
das lässt er nicht gelten
ohne eu agrarsubventionen hätte
eigentlich weiter breit kommt kaum noch
ein bauer zurechtkommen in meinen augen
sind das ja auch spenden die vom staat
kommen und und da muss der steuerzahler
der muss sozusagen zwangsweise das geld
zur verfügung stellen und die spenden
die gekommen sind ja absolut freiwillig
die tägliche schlacht am kalten buffet
ihre rinder zeigen gefühle wie freude
und trauer sagt das paar die tiere leben
im familienverbund streiten sich und
schließen freundschaften
[Musik]
die lehre kann sich auf rund 20 hektar
weideland frei bewegen das projekt soll
nachdenklich machen das andere ist aber
auch sicher dass wenn ich mit dem
zeigefinger kommen das finde ich sagen
du bist böse weil du das und das machst
oder
dass wir blutige bilder aus dem
schlachthof taugen
sondern
dass wir das mit humor machen also dass
ich einfach positiv versuche zu
vermitteln wie toll
rinder sind schön sie sind dass man
lustige dinge mit ihnen erlebt
so wie jetzt
er war klar danken
[Gelächter]
ein guten länder hat es karin mück
besonders angetan
als kalt musste er mit einem zirkus
durch die lande ziehen bis das
veterinäramt eingeschritten ist
statt zum schlachthof kann der junge
ochse nach booten land
und hier bekommt er nun regelmäßig seine
kuscheleinheiten
ohne dafür kunststücke zeigen zu müssen